and so on behalf of the government the
state and its citizens
i apologize for the profound
generational wrong
visited upon irish mothers and their
children
who ended up in a mother and baby home
or a county home
as the commission says plainly they
should not
have been there i apologize
for the shame and stigma which they were
subjected to
and which for some remains abortion to
this day
in apologizing i want to emphasize that
each of you
were in an institution because of the
wrongs of others
each of you is blameless each of you did
nothing wrong
and has nothing to be ashamed of
each of you deserved so much better
the lack of respect for your fundamental
dignity
and rights as mothers and children
who spend time in these institutions is
homely economically acknowledged and
deeply
deeply regretted the irish state
as the main funding authority for the
majority of these institutions
had the ultimate ability to exert
control
over these institutions in addition to
its duty of care
to protect citizens with a robust
regulatory
and inspection regime
this authority was not exerted
and the state's duty of care was not
upheld
the state failed you the mothers and
children
in these homes
the report brings a considerable amount
of previously unknown information into
the public domain
it has exposed the truth once hidden
to reveal significant failures of the
state the churches
and of society women were admitted to
modern baby homes and county homes
because no supports were forthcoming
from any other
quarter they were forced to leave home
and seek a place where they could stay
without having to pay
many were destitute in the personal
testimonies
of how many mothers ended up in these
institutions
the priest the doctor
and the non-loom large
the sense of oppression even at this
distance
is overwhelming mothers
terrified by the consequences of their
pregnancy
becoming known to their family and
neighbors entered mother and baby homes
to protect
their secret and the pressure to
maintain this
secret added insult to injury and was a
large part
of the mother's trauma conditions in the
homes
varied before the 1960s
living conditions in many private irish
households were generally poor
in the congregated settings of mother
and baby homes poor sanitary conditions
had much more serious consequences for
disease
and infection control county homes
as well as kill russian tomb are
identified as having
appalling conditions conditions
in other modern baby homes were better
and improved over time
many of the mothers suffered emotional
abuse and were often subject to
denigration
and derogatory remarks from the
religious with little kindness
shown especially when giving birth
the overall picture is of a hard
cold and uncaring environment
one of the most disquieting features of
the report
is that up until 1960 mother and baby
homes appear to have significantly
reduced
the prospects of survival of children
the death rate among infants in mother
and baby homes was almost twice
that of the national average for
children born outside of marriage
a total about of about 9 000 children
died in the institutions under
investigation
about 15 of all the children who were in
their care it is deeply distressing to
note
that the very high mortality rates were
known
to local and national authorities at the
time
and were recorded in official
publications
however there is little or no evidence
of state intervention in response to
these chilling statistics
and debts in fact a number of reports
actually identifying the problems were
not acted
on i know it will be a disappointment
that the report does not answer all the
deeply personal questions
on the burial arrangements for many of
the children who died in these
institutions
in many cases the burial locations
remains
unknown and uncertain there are no
records for a number of the large
institutions
where significant numbers of infants are
known to have died
including chum bezborough castle pollard
and shan ross
while this is difficult options for
dignified remembrance and memorial
memorialization
will be implemented where this is not
already the case
while mothers may not have been strictly
legally forced to enter these homes
the fact is that most had no alternative
especially those who did not have the
support of their family
or in independent financial means
overall the commission concludes that
ireland was a cold
and harsh environment for the majority
of its residents during the earlier half
of the period under investigation it was
especially cold
and harsh for women all women suffered
serious discrimination
women who gave birth outside marriage
were subject to particularly harsh
treatment emerging from the survivor
stories
are the horrific accounts of rape either
perpetrated within families
or by someone within a woman's community
this had led ultimately to entry into a
modern baby home
where the woman bore a social stigma but
there was no accountability
for the men responsible and the agencies
of the state
showed little or no interest in
addressing these crimes
the commission acknowledges the
additional impact which a lack of
knowledge and
understanding had on the treatment and
outcomes of mothers and children with
different racial and cultural heritage
those who faced mental health challenges
are those with physical
and intellectual disabilities such
discriminatory attitudes exacerbated
the shame and stigma felt by some of our
most vulnerable citizens
especially where opportunities for
non-institutional payment
placement of children were restricted by
an unjust belief
that they were unsuitable for placement
with families
while context is essential to our proper
understanding of this chapter of our
history
it does not listen what happened or
diminish the responsibility
of churches and state for the failures
laid bare
in what we have learned for much of the
period covered by the commission
women as a group and regardless of age
or class
were systematically discriminated
against in relation to employment
family law and social welfare solely
because of their gender children
were similarly unequal and none more so
than those who were cruelly
labeled illegitimate i shared deeply the
commission's unequivocal view
that the existence of the status of
image illegitimacy until 1987
in this country was an egregious breach
of human rights
this was a huge injustice and blighted
the lives of many
it is a sad truth that the history of
humankind even to today
has largely been defined by a failure to
acknowledge and vindicate
the rights and status of women and the
labeling of those who fail to conform to
social norms
we cannot account for what happened
elsewhere but we can
and must do so for what happened in our
country
an apology on its own is not enough
we collectively in this house will be
judged by our actions
actions always speak louder than words
the government accepts and will respond
to all of the recommendations made by
the commission
and this response will center on four
pillars of recognition
remembrance records and restorative
recognition
recognition begins with this apology and
will be followed by commitments to
national and local memorialization
and commemoration the views and wishes
of former residents will be paramount
and all commemoration will be led by
them
a broad suite of memorialization
education and research commitments
will support national reflection and
enduring remembrance
future generations will learn of mother
and baby homes
and of the experiences of former
residents particularly as told
through their own words with regard to
records
the government is committed to
introducing information and tracing
legislation
as a priority access to one's identity
is a basic right we will also be
advancing a range of
related actions to support access to
personal information
and to assure appropriate and sensitive
archiving of institutional records
finally returning turning to restorative
recognition
similar to the magletons an enhanced
medical card will be given to former
residents of a mother and baby home
or county home this is in addition to
counseling
which is immediately available to all
former residents
and patient liaison support services
which will be available to all
former residents the government will
also design a scheme of restorative
recognition
for former residents and an
inter-departmental group will report
back
to government on this as soon as
possible
all of these commitments will be
advanced in a survivor-centered manner
with ongoing communications and
engagement as plans are developed
and implemented as a nation
it is important to understand and accept
the failings of our past important but
not sufficient
we must also learn from them we have
adopted national international laws
which oblige us to follow a different
more humane
and rights-based approach there is in
place and being far to develop the wide
range
of social services completely absent for
much of our history
under minister o'gorman we have a
government department dedicated to
children
to equality into working across
government and society
to promote and uphold the rights of all
people
the citizens assembly is examining
further measures to address structural
inequalities in relation to gender it is
looking in particular at how we can
support and respond to the needs of
those
with caring responsibilities through our
laws and policies
our systems structures and services our
actions and our words
we must always seek to create a more
just society
grounded in respect diversity
tolerance and equality continued
investment in education
especially for those at the margins and
the most vulnerable
is the surest way of making sure that we
do not repeat the past
similarly we must learn the lesson
that institutionalization creates power
structures
and abuses of power and must never again
be an option for our country in any
circumstance
throughout this report former residents
talk
of a feeling of shame for the situation
they found themselves in
the shame was not theirs it was
ours it was our shame that we did not
show them
the respect and compassion which we as a
country owe them
it remains our shame i want to reassure
survivors
their families and the country
that this government is determined to
act on all the recommendations of the
report
and to deliver the legislative change
necessary
to at least start to heal the runes that
endure
thank you alaskan caller thank you for
your indulgence thank you